[Musique]
comment réparer des cordes vocales
endommagées les traitements disponibles
ne sont pas toujours idéaux une équipe
de l'université Mégane pour savoir
trouver le remède miracle un gel
injectable
[Musique]
cette machine parle elle parle sans
arrêt depuis une heure pourtant elle ne
raconte rien
ce larynx artificiel c'est l'outil de
travail de Luc monjeau et lui permet
d'étudier les mécanismes de la voix
[Musique]
la communication parliez est essentielle
ou bien déjà on le voit pas dans la
période de pandémie peut parler pendant
des grandes périodes c'est pas très bon
pour le moral alors c'est un aspect qui
m'a toujours fasciné
derrière la voie humaine se cache du
tissus remarquables les cordes vocales
elles doivent résister à quelques 200
vibrations par seconde mais ces tissus
ne sont pas à toute épreuve avec l'usure
ou certaines maladies les cordes vocales
peuvent finir par s'engager dans les cas
graves il n'y a aucune solution
permanente pour récupérer la voix
les traitements actuels que mettons les
injections de botox ou de choses comme
ça sont des solutions à court terme
alors le problème c'est que les
matériaux qu'on injecte avec le temps se
dégradent et après 3 à 4 mois en fait
sont éliminés par l'organisme et puis à
ce moment-là on doit rien injecter
intervalles périodique
depuis 10 ans le professeur de
l'université migil et son équipe sont à
la recherche du matériau parfait pour
réparer les cordes vocales ils croient
avoir trouvé la recette miracle un
hydrogel un gel réparateur à base d'eau
injecter dans les cordes vocales il se
solidifie pour leur donner du volume et
combler les lésions et c'est là que la
magie opère
il va aider à recruter les cellules car
il est pour eux puis les cellules vont
pouvoir se promener à l'intérieur de
l'hydrogène et commencer la régénération
mais un matériau synthétique comme
l'hydrogel ne peut rester dans le corps
des cancers risquaient de se développer
l'hydrogène sert donc d’échafaudage de
structures ou cellules pour reconstruire
le tissu les cellules migrent dans le
matériau à travers ses ports et se
multiplient après deux mois le gel est
désintégré le nouveau tissu abrit toute
sa place
pour que ça fonctionne il faut que les
propriétés mécaniques du gel soit
similaires assez déçus et le tissu qui
nous intéresse c'est les cordes vocales
s'il y a un tissu qui est très très mou
c'est pour ça que l'hydrogène est très
mou très flexible mais en maintenant il
est capable de supporter des efforts
mécaniques très élevés alors on peut les
tirer beaucoup sans qu'il se déchire ou
qu'il se brise
une panoplie de gel poreuse existe déjà
seulement ils sont peu élastiques ils ne
peuvent donc pas supporter les
vibrations des cordes vocales Luc
Mongeot Miss toutefois sur un ingrédient
clé le kites-en glicole c'est un dérivé
du kitosanes un glucide produit à partir
de carapace de crustacés dans le gel les
molécules de kitesanes glycolent se lit
entre elles ensemble elles forment un
réseau élastique qui empêche le matériau
de se déchirer
pour tester cette élasticité on pousse
l'hydrogel assez limite on les tire
jusqu'à ce qu'il se brise le matériau
montre l'étendue de ses capacités il
prend trois fois sa longueur d'origine
c'est ce qui nous vont en fait il y
avait pas de matériaux comme ça en
existe
[Musique]
mais avant d'être utilisé chez l'humain
le gel doit faire ses preuves dans des
conditions similaires à celle du corps
on l’injecte dans les cordes vocales du
larynx artificiel et pour reproduire un
environnement naturel on lui ajoute des
cellules de cordes vocales humaines
pendant deux semaines on fait parler de
la machine une heure par jour les cordes
vocales de silicone vibre à la même
fréquence que chez Dumas un ventilateur
joue le rôle du poumon
une fois le monologue terminé on scrute
les cordes vocales le gel annule le coup
les cellules des cordes vocales qui
abritent en migré partout elles se sont
bien acclimatées alors nouvelle
environnement les cellules ont aussi
produit beaucoup de collagène signent
qu'ils sont en pleine réparation pour
les chercheurs c'est une grande victoire
il y a tellement d'échecs qui mènent la
réussite que quand finalement quelque
chose qui fonctionne et qui passent tous
les tests c'est quelque chose de
formidable pour tous les bouts tous les
étudiants qui contribuent
le gel est présentement en effet
pré-clinique sur les cordes vocales de
lapin lorsque les chercheurs auront le
feu vert ils pourrontester le produit
sur les humains et déjà ses propriétés
vont entrevoir des applications au-delà
des cordes vocales comme l'impression
d'organe en trois dimensions
ça permettrait des tests à long terme de
de régénération titulaire mais ça
pourrait aussi éventuellement permettre
la création de prothèses ou bien ou à
tester des médicaments par exemple
la recherche sur de tels matériaux et
jeunes et en ébullition
de toutes sortes d'application pour les
biométriews et ouais c'est une course
mondiale beaucoup beaucoup de gens à
travers le monde qui travaillent dans ce
domaine et c'est notre domaine très
excitant avec beaucoup de découverte
d'innovation
[Musique]